just from attendance
foreign
thank you very much for that as you can
see ladies and gentlemen it's um
it's going to be a little bit different
than the normal council meeting
um we've got the one mic here when we
get to the
items on the agenda that any councillors
wish to speak on i'm afraid i'm gonna
have to ask you to
leave your seat and come up to where um
canada is sitting
to actually use the microphone there i'm
afraid
because otherwise the ones at the back
the rooms
are fairly long we will never hear what
people are saying
okay um item three then sorry no item
two second item is
a confirmation of the three sets of
minutes which is the extra only meeting
held on the 29th of march
uh the full council meeting on the 12th
of april
on the agm on the 26th of april
we'll start obviously with the 29th of
april
page
page four page five
eight six page seven
page eight
[Music]
gets two votes she's better looking for
me
she's more educated than me so i think
i think we're just struggling to have a
look and see exactly what there's some
pencil manly
where is she got two books
[Music]
um
moving on to the 12th of april
page 13 14
15 16
17 18
19 20
21 22
yes you you're quite right on page 22
you can see councilman mandela
was actually there uh as
yeah she has voted twice there well
spotted cancer thanks
23 24
25
on page 26.
move on then to the next one the 26th of
april
page 27 28
29 30
31 32
33 34
35 36
37 38
39 40
41 42
43 94
45 46 47
48 49
50 51
52 53
4 55 56
57 58
59 60
61 62
63 64
65 66
67 68
69 17
71 72
73 on page 74.
reminded me of bengal
that was
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
again
okay
the next seven minutes and then was 12
and april which i've gone through
[Music]
against on abstentions
and lastly the agm minutes which is the
26th of april
on fiverr
again abstentions
thank you the
third item on the agenda is public
contributions
declarations of interest well you all
know the score uh on that uh
that department so you have any
declaration one item comes up on agenda
i can file the agreement between items
part one and the generations part one
and two
i have a proposal for that please i'll
propose that
second case
uh consider item six consider
correspondence received
by the chair either whatever
item seven is to answer questions
submitted under procedure rule
89 we have three questions
was going to be asked to present this
first
okay so i'll just receive what i'm doing
okay um and the
the next one is uh uh counts requesting
right thank you um thank you for the
answer um
i trust if the officers are having talks
they are going to include the three
eastern water councillors
with us because i think that's very
important um
my supplementary question um you'll
notice on our agenda tonight we've got a
very detailed
explanation of what we're submitting for
in the leveling up fund
um this money that i've talked about my
first part of the question comes from
what i understand it's called the land
release
fund and i'd like to ask when was that
funding
applied for who signed it off and were
councillors involved because i don't
remember ever hearing about that
and the reason i'm asking this that any
award would clearly
i think become a material consideration
in terms of planning
given that it referred to the sale of
publicly owned land
answers
the details uh with us tonight so we'll
provide cancer christie with a written
response
well we thought something might have
known who signed it off but there we are
okay well as chief exec
has just said a written answer will be
will be
provided um
the next question uh was uh from council
hicks
[Music]
[Music]
x
[Music]
uh this matter is brought to me by the
age of
representing the farmers
it is a very large dairy farm
and it has a problem it's causing
pollution it knows it is
it wants to deal with it the environment
agency wants it to deal with it
the problem is water
in this summer he made a planning
application
it's been battered forth and back
with no apparent common sense as to
what the council are looking for
councillor acting as agent for natural
england
who are dealing with something it's new
rules
and they don't seem to know what's going
on
um i'm told that on the first
task the farm failed by four percent
they can spray it's a bit like
vetting pack or something the yards
you get rid of a lot of this smell after
sniff call it what you'd like put it
well
under the requirement but the council
don't apparently want to consider that
now they've got to start work
there is the truth of it because
winter is looking at us and it's
more important to be perfectly honest
stop polluting water forces
then it is the atmosphere where
the answer is live with it for a fair
while
but really torridge has got to get on
top of this problem
because we've probably got more dairy
cows than any other district in the
country
we're going to be getting this more and
more
and i would suggest that our officers
need to get gender up on it properly
not relying on somebody from natural
england
who's had to file dumped in front of
them until what to do
can't run like this
[Music]
okay that takes care of those three
questions the
right to mate on the gender is uh
tolerances potential
carbon plan this is pages 75 to
108. sure
if they're a personal uh paid qualified
mentioned elms
the environmental management system so
it's part of my business thought for the
future so i declare a personal interest
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much good evening ladies
and gentlemen
i'm very pleased to be before you
tonight for your
uh review and approval hopefully um a
draft
carbon environmental biodiversity plan
for choice district council
as members will recall um you
committed to um uh
committed the torture street council to
reach net carbon 20 by 2030
and following your declaration of a
climate emergency
um since that time uh quite a bit of
work has been done
although the development of this plan
has obviously been delayed by yeah
covered
um but one of the uh the main
commitments
that's been made is the uh approval of
the of the new strategic
plan which obviously commits us
to our environment our future and
various tasks
underneath that strategic plan the
adoption of the carbon plan being one of
those
um the plan that is
uh has been produced with the with the
help of the
member climate emergency working group
and i'm very
grateful for their support and direction
and the development of the plan
um the report gives a a summary
of what's in the plan and it
provides information that the drivers
for declaring
a climate emergency using uh up-to-date
uh data and
information um it acknowledges the
achievements that have already been made
by
torres district council and it also
puts the plan in the context of wider
direction and commitments from from
other agencies such as the
left and devon county council
the particular interest members will be
the list of priorities
and plans uh with the list of priorities
and plans that's given on page
103 of the bundle
um those are broken down into the
headings of energy
transport planning biodiversity
wisdom recycling the council and our
communities
members may be interested to uh to know
that we have now
employed a sustainability and climate
officer
that's a joint course with north devon
and donna sibley started with us
a few weeks ago she's already
started on the carbon audit
for this authority which will be used to
develop the priorities into this plan if
approved
going forward
i believe that councilor himself lead
member for
uh carbon and the climate emergency
would like to speak um but after that
i'd be happy to take
any questions or comments from members
that's lahaines
[Music]
like to thank uh janet williams for her
brilliant work she's a delight to work
with she's
incredibly efficient she's taken note of
all our comments and concerns
and research them and responded and
put them into the carbon plan um so i'd
like to thank you very much for
producing
an excellent document i'd also like to
thank the working group
uh climate change working group
emergency
working group for all their work as well
and i look forward to working with our
new
joint officer with north devon donna
and basically i commend this carbon plan
to members
thank you
thank you catherine
have you finished here i have thank you
very much
uh
is there a social segment within there
that deals with farming practices
eg slurry distributions and things like
that
working with our uh with the
agricultural sector is an important part
of the plan
both ours and county councils
developing their carbon plan um
probably more around land management to
be honest and the the issues that
council hicks raised
would be more about nuisance and
immediate environmental impacts
and but i think it's it's it's hand in
hand it's part and parcel
so while it's not explicit in the plan
and
promoting sustainable practices and best
practices in the agricultural sector
is certainly um the direction that we
want to go in um as part of this plan
and devon county council's plan as well
it was coach ray tragerando yeah thank
you thank you mr chairman
yeah i just want to answer uh didn't
answer on uh in the introduction it says
in the first paragraph where
that we will personally reach net corbin
natural mutuality by 2013.
does that mean that um as pop stars fly
around the world
that they go off and plant a thousand
trees
to reach that uh net carbon uh
neutrality and you know is that
something the council this council is
going to do because
if we're going to just uh do that by
um offsetting our carbon is that
something that this trench is going to
do
uh councillor i think offsetting will
potentially be part of our plan in terms
of reaching
uh net neutrality by by 2030
and until we have quantified our carbon
footprint
it's difficult to say how much of a need
there will be
for that and i would imagine that most
of our
um priority will be around our estate
and our flint as well particularly the
waste fleet
and luckily we don't have many air miles
and that the council used at the moment
i don't think that's going to be
something that we need to worry about
and but the the cabin audit
is a priority for our new climate
officer
and that will certainly provide um
further um thought for us in terms of
our priorities going forward
can i just come back sorry
that that means that torrance won't stop
producing carbon by
2030 offsetting
is the is the final answer
to get to our net neutrality ambition
and we will need to look at everything
that we do
and try and reduce that as much as
possible but we may have to be prepared
for some offsetting at some point in the
future
uh we've got councillor newton first and
then councilman jones
and i'll come here sorry uh returning on
that theme
can you actually be more specific and
say that you will consider offsetting
as the last possible resort
in that a lot of offset offsetting is
um involves tree planting we know
that trees will not grow to a point
where they actually
make a positive impact until after
we've we've passed the point of no
return
so actually tree planting sounds good
in reality it's not affected and
offsetting invariably is just an excuse
to kick the can down the road
and to find a a different way to get out
of it
whereas real cuts are much
harder to take but need to be taken and
therefore can we treat offsetting
as an act of last resort really thank
you
mr jones thank you i think there's a lot
within this report which is
very important to be welcomed and i
think love made a good point that we do
need to
balance the needs of our rural economy
and our partners and make sure that
things are done in a sensible and
balanced way
i think also we need to be looking at
things which are within our control and
i know that we've made a lot of
what we return quick wins already but i
noticed on page 92
we don't explicitly refer to the amount
of
carbon spended by officers commuting to
work offices to users of meetings
members commuting to meetings
things like that i mean i think we
should be doing a lot more
virtual meetings hopefully you will be
allowed to do that
the government but are the council
looking at
flexible work and practices for their
staff if they want them to try and
reduce their commuting and things like
that
the other thing i i just thought i'd say
was
i don't particularly like the idea that
we will be a
lobby group as it says on the in the
report says that we will not be
government
things i i don't think we should be
committing
as a council in in such old terms to
being a group which lobbies i think if
things
come up on an individual basis that
perhaps we
can consider writing to our mp or such
but i don't think we should be having as
a foundation standpoint that we are a
loving group
that we will continuously push
rather than challenging central
government policy thank you mr general
thank you um i've got council brenton
first and then comes from valentine
thank you chair uh well we've just
completed a
self-built project house and i have to
say that
in that process building control is very
vague in fact we could have had gas
installed
in in the new build which is just
ridiculous isn't it we should
we in this authority should be making
sure we've got some very tight rules
vis-a-vis
uh what what new build should comply
with i mean i go around and see these
new estates and i don't know i think
well
the expense that we went to we had under
floor heating
electric heating from uh denmark we had
insulation board that had to come from
germany uh we're
in the towards the end we actually found
that we had to have
solar panels we didn't know that at the
beginning
but we finally had to have them and then
we were told well actually if you have
more than six
you're going to go back to planning to
get permission to have more although
ridiculous is that it just didn't make
any sense at all
and i mean i'm reasonably uh okay with
building control having
built a house 25 years ago so but but we
really should be
putting a direct steer into new building
a lot of stuff in the pipeline new
planning permissions are they going to
be compliant and make sure that they
they are carbon neutral what is the
point otherwise
you know i know he's doing it in
hindsight let's get it up front and do
it
just two brief questions share page 83
uh the graph there on co2 emissions
i see there's two entries at the bottom
of the
graph legends both regarding to
agriculture forestry and then
land use and then fishing activities i
would like to
understand what the difference is
between the green and the yellow
because it's not very explanatory and
secondly my point would be
can targe start on a positive position
when it comes to zero carbon
because we already have a prolifer of
trees everywhere
and to be adding more trees seems to be
causing more trouble giving the number
of trees blown down this winter and
caused huge
difficulties around our transport system
so that's two points i would like to
record here please
yeah i'm happy to uh try to respond to
uh
two of those um in terms of the figure
one
uh graph on page 83
i must admit i hadn't noticed that
before and we've taken that from the
uh from devon county council's um uh
calvin plan
so if i may i'll need to go back to the
dem and and
get that qualification i'm happy to do
that council pennington
um noted on the on the trees um
yeah um
we'll take that i'll take that as uh
advisement as well
um just to pick up on another couple of
points um
chair and flexible working we are
reviewing flexible working at the moment
obviously it's a balance between um
providing essential services and but
also
trying to meet our carbon commitment the
technology certainly helps
and we've learned a lot over the past
year um in in that regard
and in relation to new build um
completely take on board what the member
says there
and obviously the review of the local
plan um
will be an important part um of the of
the carbon plan
um not that it is part of the campaign
but it will be something that
will um assist us for um those points
so um that will be the opportunity for
for
members and both uh general devon and to
lobby
and for those sort of um measures
that the member sites thank you chair
thank you uh councillor hicks and maybe
honor
thank you very very
i think this carbon plan
should ban the use of plants
because they're not made of lead they're
made of graphite
carbon and the wood that surrounds them
that's a lot of carbon in there
thank you
hopefully this is the last one there's
council haines
thank you yeah i want just to thank
everybody for their input
some interesting point points made as
sir jan
said about if you're the local plan um
i'm very much aware of the lead to input
into the revision of the local plan in
terms of the environment and the carbon
emergency
the present local plan is pretty weak in
some respects on that
so we're very much aware of the working
group but
to other members are as well
um the point about trees i do take the
point that
uh you know it's starting a dream takes
a while
to establish in terms of carbon off
setting but that's not an argument not
plant increase we have to think we have
to think of the future in future
generations
and certainly tree planting does
contribute to
reducing emissions um
point about well not using pencils well
pass that by i think but the point about
paper i think is important
members possibly to think about not
having paper agendas in minutes
because that's churning those out
for councillors takes a huge amount of
united paper so
perhaps you could think about that um as
to the point about
lobby well i think councillor jones
mentioned having more
virtual meetings well as i understand
that the local government association is
not it's actually nothing on our behalf
to have more virtual meetings
so the two go together but anyway thanks
very much
bouncers
and castle unlock just to finish
light-hearted though it says that we
would um
implement electric charging points i
don't know if anyone picked up today but
there was a tourist bus
in cornwall with an all-electric tourist
bus somewhere around cornwall
especially around kahuba's bay and he
could find no way to
know where to recharge his coach and the
tourism staff
well if i could have the last word on
this and i
i i totally agree with the council of
brenton on
his the point that he made about new
builds
i don't profess to be to know everything
in the document network that we're
discussing an israeli complex issue
but a couple of weeks ago at the term
council we had a presentation
from the developers of the new cleve
woods site at top of eastern oregon
220 houses very nice presentation
there's some
really nice properties but i did ask the
question
you know where where's the where's the
soda where's the pv where's the
ground source heat pumps where's the car
you know electric car charge report you
know and it was a complete absence of
that
and i i you know the answer that i got
was
you know clearly that they don't have to
put this in it's not in
any of the regulations so at the moment
they're not doing that
i did encourage them that uh it would be
perhaps perhaps they should be the first
developer in this area to do that
and use them as a selling point for
their for the properties
they did take those points on board but
one of them
council haynes i should introduce this
motion would you like to propose this
because it has to be voted on
yeah i think i propose that uh
councillors
accept and approve this uh
please share
okay
thank you
[Music]
okay that's food carry okay the next
item on the agenda
is i have nine cancer allowances
[Music]
sorry achieve exactly mistake on this
thanks j um so a very brief report uh
the original report
that this refers to was brought to full
council on the 27th of january
2020 and at that council meeting
members resolved uh most of the
recommendations that came from the
remuneration panel um but elected
that to be referred back to the panel
for
reconsideration and they were in terms
of
vice chairs and remuneration for that
role for the
various committees and whether
lead members should be receiving
a special responsibility and now
allowance
the panel reconvened and
reached their same conclusion as they
did the first time
that there is no evidence to suggest
that
vice vice chairs should receive a
separate
allowance and likewise for
lead members they have
they have said in the report
that they would reconsider that again
at the next review should any more
information come to light from members
okay so the the recommendations in the
report
on page 111
that the the chair standards committee
received a special rememberation
set 1.4 times basic allowance
as that was missed out to the original
report
that vice chairs or committees should
not receive an allowance but the
expectation being that
chairs would share their allowances if
they were asking advice
to step into the role on a regular basis
the chairs and vice chairs rules to be
fully reviewed in future
deliberations for the panel that lead
members
should also not receive an allowance and
that further lead members roles be
reviewed
uh in future deliberations should
evidence to support
the case be provided chair happy to take
any questions
[Music]
there you go gentlemen ladies
and gentlemen thank you mr chairman
i agree with all the recommendations in
this report
apart from uh number b
i think we should continue to pay
vice chairs it is a very modest sum
that we pay them and i find the proposal
that chairs should share their
allowances
with their vice chairs slightly
preposterous
um not that i'm saying that chairs would
be
dishonest enough to refuse to do it
but i think it is inappropriate i think
vice chairs
lend support to their chairman when
they're setting agendas
they're a listening ear and sometimes
they can offer
support and information that the chairs
may not be aware of
so i think it is a slightly more
different role than that of an ordinary
committee member i commend the rest of
these recommendations
to full council and i would support them
all
with the exception of b being amended to
say that
by shares should continue to be paid
thank you thank you council
uh question chair i
i would disagree with councillor
the responsibility rests for the
committee
and the workings of the committee rests
with the chair
and the allowance should be linked to
the responsibility if the chair is not
able to discharge that responsibility
then the vice in effect steps up and
of course then a proportion would go to
them so personally i would not support
that
proposal thank you
thanks for watching recommendation why
don't we
fully i think the issue is not that we
pay close chairs but voice chairs
actually
step up and take some of the
responsibility and do the job and in my
experience
that has happened
[Music]
the suggestion made that chairs could
share some of their allowance um with
the vice chair
if they have to um step in
you know on a few occasions for whatever
reason
i would imagine i don't know but um i
would imagine that could be
quite difficult for the actual office to
actually manage that situation because
as we know we you get your allowance
paid into your bank or whatever
and if that that amount is a fairly
consistent amount what happens if all of
a sudden there is an
interruption in that and then it has to
be
some a portion of that how much would
have to be awarded i don't know but
to the vice chair could get quite
complicated could it
um chair i agree yes it would be quite
difficult
um i guess what we reported is the the
findings or
findings of the remuneration panel they
didn't go into
any specific details about um
the amounts the shares and so forth
it was a recommendation made by the
panel without
any supplementary detail okay thank you
my advice here i would like to say a
word i think you want some of my loans
right
that's all right i'll speak that um
i'm actually vice chair of two
committees
uh the full council and also the
crematorium and
uh neither of which i get paid for so i
don't think i have to declare an
interest
um i support council movement on this
uh the vice chairs very rarely have to
chair a meeting in my experience
and i've always been against paying vice
chairs what i would like to see actually
when the
this remuneration committee meets next
time is that league members
actually do get some money because the
league members in my experience
do a lot of work far more than vice
chairs
ever do and i think next time if we are
going to
ask them to look again at this that we
look again at
playing lead members because it is an
onerous post actually
but vice chairs now i'm completely
against playing many of them
okay well it's been proposed and
seconded
that they accept the recommendations
apart from
would be i think it was uh vice chairs
no it's all right except um let's don't
propose the second dude
so can we have a show of hands
all the recommendations here on page 111
with the exception that vice chairs
continue
to be paid the special responsibility
allowance
yes thank you um can i suggest that we
take
a c d and e together and take b
separately please because i i don't
think they've been knocked in
together because it seems the beers or
what which is being controversial so i'd
suggest
you yes
okay me to change my recommendations if
you would please yeah
if you would please well i i stand by
the recommendation i made
i don't see why there is a problem
taking a vote in accepting
acdme with a change an amendment
that i propose to be
but taking advice from our legal team
our head of legal services do you want
me to change is
is it inappropriate that i make that
amendment because i don't see it
you can propose an amendment provided
the second agrees that amendment
well my second i did so
an amendment to the recommendations in
the report
councillor james ii did that so you
could take that
amendment first members will vote
on that amendment um and that would may
then fall into the
substantive motion or not okay
is that what you were saying casper
let the chief executive just clarify
exactly what it is we're looking for
chair thanks uh for those members so you
vote in first of all on councillor
hudson's
amendment uh to item b
on page 111 which is that vice chairs
continue to be paid special
responsibility allowance
so that's the amendment that you're only
voting on
first then depending on whether that's
carried or not you'll vote
on may substantive the rest of the
recommendations as a
since that devotion okay
i'll accept the changes that our chief
exec has made
because it would be a point of clarity
for everybody else who seems to be
confused by this
that i i make an amendment to be
that we will continue to pay vice chairs
okay everyone clear on that
yeah yes okay it's been proposed and
seconded
so show off hands for that and that vice
chairs continue together
against
okay we now come on to the actual
document itself then that needs to be
voted on someone i can propose
the rest of the document sorry then
you didn't have to vote
all the measures
uh against
[Music]
once that's currently done
ladies and gentlemen
item 10 is the play strategy which is
page 118 to 125
and to receive uh a report from the head
of communities in place
he's already on his way to the
microphone yeah thank you chair
um so hopefully the report in front of
you describes the evolution of the play
strategy to its eventual reduction
uh what main remains to be resolved is
the difference of opinion between the
scrutiny committees
and community resources about the
allocation of a specific budget
so as there's a difference of opinion it
comes to full council for you to make
revenge of course so that just leaves us
with the recommendation on page 122.
thank you i'm happy to take any
questions as well of course
okay ladies and gentlemen any questions
that you would like to ask
sure thank you very much mr chairman mr
kearney
given a recent news 11 and up funds and
we seem to go on
majorly in the black may i please now
ask at this juncture
to have my disabled swings back into the
play strategy i've been trying for six
years and i
will not give up mr kearney so can i
please add those to the list
certainly there is no list yet
um but there is an intention within the
strategy to provide
play facilities for disabled people so
certainly it's a consideration
any other questions
okay just
because i was the chair of an external
um
just say that a press report came before
the external ons committee on the 18th
november
um quite shocked and one particular
report
done by tivoli at the time um to
show that victoria park was in a very
poor state of repair
um he said the stampede says santa is
hazardous
lucian is abrasive and is transferred to
other places equipment is impacts on
their condition
um also covered offensive articles
and there's also reports of incidents
and injuries
and what concerned me when i made the
single calling
on the cnr recommendation that we have
no budget
is that if there is injuries occurring
in the play park and then we as a full
council
say we have no budget for maintenance
it's a little bit of a team that runs
through the stretchers it seems like
that we can build something but we
cannot maintain it
and to say in a report committee at the
end of discussion with cnr i think it
was on the 1st of february
that we have no budget i don't think is
a very wise thing to do
given that there was a reports of
injuries already taking place at
victoria park
and that was the reason why i singularly
as chair of external owners put it in
that i agreed that it went to internal
and that's because it isn't financial
matter
but it is the the is about the
environment we don't have an environment
member any longer um about what state we
want
our areas to be in and we need to make
sure we have the money
if we are going to have these areas or
we don't put them up in the first place
and that was my drive behind
my comments thank you jeremy thank you
casual
ask chad just just before sorry ken
before i bring up the leader and i'll
just let you all in yes
so so just to provide a little bit of
context around counterfeiting its
comments there
those debates were had um just for
clarity the county stock potential
doesn't have a budget for repairing play
areas it's just not a specific budget
for play areas
there's a responsive maintenance budget
so if a swing breaks we have a budget
to replace that swing um but it's just
not specifically running fans for play
coaches james thank you well i actually
started playing strategy
some three years ago or so i was trapped
because i was concerned about that their
stuff wasn't being maintained
the issue is not that we have no
maintenance budget
the issue is we have no no
information to show what we need to do
to these play areas
so we're putting the cart before the
horse we have 170
000 in our general maintenance
pot of which about 40 000 a year so it
goes to
maintenance of play areas what we need
to do is get on with the play strategy
and get a true picture of what we're
going to do with the play areas
which ones we're going to keep which
we're going to maintain
under the revenue budget and which ones
we are going to look to
to put capital to and once we get a
proper
thing and my only frustration is not
with this
report so much it's the fact we aren't
getting on with the play strategy we
really do need a picture
of our play areas of which ones we want
to keep
which ones the community wants to take
on and
how much money we need to split between
revenue
and capital but just setting a revenue
budget
specifically for maintenance is like
guessing the length of the piece of
string at this moment
let's get the strategy sorted out a true
picture of what we need
and then do it if we chop and change her
we will have to chop and change
budget there is money in there to do it
we just need to get on with the job
thank you chad thank you guys i've been
coaching my girlfriend and then coastal
canada
yeah thank you mr chairman but i thought
some time ago we actually paid inside
contractors for a survey to be done
and ordered parks that we actually owned
within torridge
so yeah that's really the report you
know that should hopefully
then address what you said councilor
james about what is actually priority
within the district where we can
actually focus the spot money too
so basically that report seems to have
gone to the weight size somewhere
i've got it with me got it i've got it
here i remember seven and report
this report was done by tivoli and i
hope the officer
will point to me if i'm wrong on this in
september
2020 which came before our committee and
it lists
all 36 play areas which porridge is
responsible for
of which nine were listed in poor
condition
and that was done nearly nine months ago
so
we're already a long way down the road
and to say we are
holding things up we're not it's about
the image and the ethos
and the environment we're trying to
cater to and towards this
place strategy is on the road but to say
there is no money for maintenance and
that was
placed in the public domain at a
decision notice
is i think quite wrong for courage to be
facing that
situation
[Music]
i've been responsible for the one
individual and we have yearly
uh lost firm inspections and stuff like
that i was surprised that we do rely on
tivoli i think that's another thing we
need to look at within the report
that we should have an outside
assessment every year
and not necessarily by the people that
actually look after the phone calls
and i quite happily propose that i talk
to the chief example
sean kearney that we do ensure that we
get proper inspection
and
the argument today is do we have a
specific budget
when we don't know what we're going to
be spending the money on
and we've got money in the general
maintenance budget to deal with the
day-to-day stuff at the moment
so it's just a breakdown between what we
should be doing what we've got money for
and what we should be planning for and
obviously when we plan
there will be revenue from agents and it
may be
that we need to find some capital
because if the stuff isn't worth
maintaining
there will be stuff we need to replace
and that would have to be in capital
which will mean we need to budget for
that in next year's budget really
you know otherwise we can't go back to
this year's budget so
it's just about trying to get our ducks
in a row and just getting organized
but for today we're keen with seeing
arnold paul
and theness report and my proposal will
be that we accept seeing our report and
just going with the job
thank you chad i would say yeah thank
you
i've got two speakers canceled crazy
first and then council
thank you um i've been waiting for two
years for this play strategy report
and i don't know when it's going to come
um until then we can't do anything with
the parks
all the um the player equipment that's
been broken
has been removed it's not being repaired
the
the surfaces underneath the player
equipment that's gone
um has not been replaced and it's a
constant battle to get anything done at
all
because it's always well we're waiting
for the play strategy
and i think if we were to commission
someone to write a play strategy
they would want to know what their
budget is because i've never heard of
anybody writing report i've had spent
what i have actually
the government had one on um tutoring in
schools
and they came up with a figure that was
about ten times what the government's
prepared to spend on it
you have to set a budget you have to
have a capital budget
to play equipment and you have to have a
revenue budget
maintenance and without those you can't
move
forward
uh sean would you like to respond to
that thank you
much of what council frankie talks about
was the
the motivation that uh brought us to
even considering
a play strategy in the first place uh
that sort of non-replacement
strategy that we hope to address
because we don't want to pursue that
anymore there'll be certain instances
where there are play areas which we wish
to do commission as per the strategy
and to be certain areas that we wish to
enhance we haven't the next step for us
is to work out which areas are in line
for what
work with our communities to see which
communities want to step up and take
things on
um and that's the next step for us in
terms of the strategy
and and just uh for clarity we we now
have a play strategy your place ratchet
was adopted
back in february
thank you chair well we did describe
discuss this
in great detail and overview and
scrutiny as council pennington said
problem is that and i think as
councillor craig just mentioned
that far too long our play areas
when any piece of equipment broke down
or was damaged
all that happened was it was removed
there was no repairs on the table
although um the officer sean
uh carney did say when we were at the
overused scrutiny committee that it
spent
quite a considerable sum on the play
areas
broken down in detail but it was about
over a five-year period i think if i'm
done researching it correctly we should
have i mean
there's many areas that we deliver
services on
and we do have a budget for repairs if
you look
we've already adopted the play strategy
to say we've not gotten those strategies
incorrect we haven't placed traffic
was adopted by cnr it's just this
element
of having a fund there a dedicated time
to replace and repair damage and
uh equipment in the play areas the fact
that we might be discussing
the italian parish councils about taking
over prayer is
a separate but we should have a
dedicated budget
and i think sean couldn't say i don't
think perhaps i've got the figures
tonight
but look at what's been spent on our
players by charge over the last
five years and divide that figure by
five and make that the budget
for going forward if at the end of the
day we don't need that budget
after 12 months it will cut the budget
down but we need a budget to draw
it's not good enough to say there is a
catch-all budget that you can go to
because if that gets spent
well we should have it to have a proper
place strategy
i move that we do have an edit dedicated
budget
and that would be bringing back to it
another meeting with us
um but i'm going to make a plea on
behalf of um
bit of the town council and the british
trust
uh i was elected mayor of business in
2019
the very first thing i did was to get an
allocation of money from the town
council which was matched by the british
trust
50 000 pounds of that money seven
thousand pounds have been spent in just
over two years
uh can i make a plea that torridge get
on with it and spend it because it is
clogging up our
budget um it just sits there and we
promised it
i'm amazed how how often do you get
offered a
load of money to spend and they're just
doing nothing
thank thank you um
yeah i agree i'm really concerned about
this because
i know there's a play strategy i
understand what the play strategy is
i have to say i have some reservations
about it because it does feel to me
as if it's a way as has already been
said it is taking time
to get anything done i mean i understood
that victoria park was going to be top
of the list but my understanding is that
even victoria park there's going to be
money raised before anything can be done
at victoria park
meanwhile if there's no set fund it just
feels like we're going to go
on and on and on with things that are
broken not being replaced
and i just feel that if we do not have a
fund that people can go to and say
that's broken it needs to be placed
things just won't be replaced you will
end up
with the credit um play areas
because things are just not happening
quick enough
so that's how i feel and i'll accept
that thank you
um thank you just to make
our parks safe just the flooring
it's frightening amounts of money and
much of
the pay equipment in all our marks for
all the parts
i've seen it's really
it's past itself by day much of the
equipment that
children are using is just hanging out
now i feel for the officers because
i feel for sure because the sort of
figure that's going to be needed
to actually make this play strategy real
and working is going to be a very
considerable
budget that this council will have to
consider
well it seems to me that you know we've
got two issues here we've got
the play strategy which is in place
we're told there is a
significant sum of money in the pot uh
ready to be used but it would also
appear that we've got councillors that
wish to see um a certain amount of money
ring fence specifically for the
maintenance of
playgrounds or playing in the play
strategy is
that my understanding yeah
i mean is is that is that possible
can we not have an element of money
rainfall specifically
in the general fund for full railways
this might be a better question for one
of the finance officers
[Music]
you know fundamentally it's the same
problem the council has got we've
separated now for the financial year
2021-22
we've got money centre-centered showing
responsible responsiveness if
there's a health and safety matter in
the parks that would be done
and we don't it's not unknown for us to
always spend maintenance but just
because we recognise that sometimes
we have to be reactive the point about
the play strategy is uh
incarceration laws will begin to
obviously we'll go through the mechanics
of that that may come into several
millions of pounds perhaps that we need
to find and we'd have to
budget accordingly for that so yes
you know i could have to get one of my
officers to do some exercise like
council that says look
i spend on play equipment and play
maintenance
but that would only be a reflection of
what we've done in the past in a
reactive way that wouldn't be a
meaningful budget
in many ways i could do that but it
doesn't change the fact that the
budget's been set for 2021-22
so i can't unchange that you've agreed
the budget that we're fixed to the total
budget
and the budget for the aid is what it is
and that's all i really wanted to say
unless you ask any questions yeah
clearly you know the pie is only so big
so
there's not any new money coming in here
i think you know the question that was
asked was
the concern was that if
if a particular budget line is spent
and then you get uh issues with a
playground or anything that needs
something you've then not got any money
for it
i mean at the end of the day the council
of this year has made a surplus probably
different council may have made
overspend previous years
you know we look at the bottom line of
the council as an entity
not as just one particular line within a
budget so
those decisions we've made at that time
if there's a significant amount of
maintenance that needed on the part then
a decision
would be made when we could meet with
any existing resources at that juncture
okay it's not a hard and fast is what
i'm trying to say
it's not a dependent the the reactive
things but it's been spent
we don't just stop just because of that
because
satisfy you oh
no because we're likely to have a
considerable underscore
reasonable understand coming up on last
year
and i think we can i think it's not it's
disingenuous
to say that we can't know because we've
set the budget for the coming year
we can't find a pot now that we can put
them into the play strategy
as a dedicated budget if there's this
reactive repair
pot there we could take some of that for
a stop and then if there is an
underspent
on last year coming forward we can put
some of that to you so
all i'm asking is that we do have a
dedicated budget
but that sean comes back to a future
full council
with some figures for us to look at
what's been spent over the last five
years on reactive maintenance in the
park
what's been taken away because we've got
a full
as councilor pennington said we've got a
full rundown of the equipment that's
missing
and what he's doing in some of our play
areas we've got that already so
it shouldn't be hard to put it together
and say no we need a budget of 60 and 70
000 pounds put to one side
to maintain our play areas i think that
might reduce all the time
if parish and town councils
[Music]
as we've been told and heard already
there's the the stock
of the play areas has been in decline
it's been reducing the quality of it is
not good or it's been removed altogether
so councillor leather's suggestion that
we
we take an average of what we spent over
the last five years
won't work because that didn't work it's
not good enough
what i would suggest and i sat i sit on
external committees so i have been
involved in
in looking at this in detail with
counselor penny
what is required is actually a sort of
pump prime inject into this to actually
bring the stock
back up to standard when we know about
it and that will be a
capital demand on the council and i
would say
and that is separate from an ongoing
routine
maintenance issue we it will make our
eyes water
because especially as many um many urban
councillors may not realize
that outing the sticks we own and run
our own play areas ourselves and they're
not
provided by taxpayer or council money
so we know the cost
of install installing play areas
and it's very expensive but i would
suggest that that is
almost a one-off capital consideration
that we need to see what is needs
to be replaced and what is the price tag
and then we can make a qualified
decision
that we can afford it over a period of
three or four years
say if we can't do it in one go but
personally i think that is the route we
should take
to not only to bring the stock up to the
right level
and until we know what it is we can't
talk money because we just don't know so
actually
as the leader said putting ring fencing
money all it does is actually
tie the hands of the section 151 officer
um
and yet it doesn't get us to a
conclusion so i would
rather see that we saw the real nature
of the problem
treated as a capital spend replacement
to get us back up to standard and that's
obviously linked in with
it takes time and i know people are
patience is thin but
um that's what i believe thank you thank
you
for generally that is exactly what's in
the play store
captain wanted to ask craig
happened to all the section 106 money
that has been set aside for faith
because there must be a budget for that
that's where they thought
and what i mean for example in the
polyfill
we've got 7 000 pounds section 106 money
which we're probably lost by now because
we have to match it
you would know that you can't find much
for seven thousand pounds
but when i went to see i can't remember
which officer it was and looked at all
the section 100 money
for per equipment there's little pots
here there
and everywhere and if you go to the
offices and you say you want to
crown fund or the town council wants to
put
25 000 pounds in they say you can't have
any fair equipment because there's no
maintenance budget you've otherwise
you've got to put in a maintenance
contract to maintain
the equipment that you put in so that's
why
we haven't got um counselor
um mcgoffs
the disabled disabled yes
that's what we haven't spent from the
benefit bridge
trust and the 25 hours of the town
council
if there is nobody that is that you can
speak to
at the council who will help you put the
equipment up
and make sure that it's maintained
because they will tell you
there is no budget there has to be a
budget
else there's no strategy you cannot have
a strategy
with no budget
[Music]
we've gone around spending huge amounts
of money over the last couple of years
and we know that there is no spare cash
around all i'm suggesting is
that and there's no going to be no
pointing your fingers
at offices but we what we need
is some honest play strategy which sets
out how much it would cost to put our
house in order
make our play park safe new equipment
where it's needed
and i know it's going to be horrible but
if we just have that figure
and then we will have to look at future
budgets
thank you
um that we accept the play strategy
in its entirety
[Music]
chair it's not about acceptance it's
about the use of
maintenance my proposal second is that
we
accept the cnr decision and that is that
there is
that at this time at least there is not
a ring fenced
so balls and seconded then that we
accept the cnr
uh recommendation correct recommendation
um that we uh accept
the the play strategy with the
[Music]
yes so the recommendation is that we're
accepting seeing our
recommendation uh regarding the place
tragedy
acknowledging that it doesn't have a
separate
maintenance budget correct
and we have a short hands for that one
please
taken any against
and abstentions
um
original motion that we just voted on
item 11 is the
non-elected members on internal uh
scrutiny
hopefully this is going to be a simple
one
someone had to propose that
seconded christine no no oh
yes um it's quite unfortunate actually
i've been asked
uh sister um i've got two names
of people uh you want i've got no
problem with them but
one of them appears on the planning
applications list today under
uh a relatively contentious application
can i ask
uh with councillors our planning
applications automatically come to the
uh planning committee who are individual
members or whatever they're called
um do they also have to come to us or do
i have to call in
jay i think we probably need to look at
those which is not for
consideration of this particular report
but um
it is a good point
okay if it's been uh been proposed
on second day we proposed
work that they do and um part of them
and the only
question i had was i know one of them
has been on the committee since 2012 has
that been a continuous
appointment from them now and secondly
have we
are we under any sort of obligation to
put this post into the public domain and
see if there is any interest and if we
have has there been any impressions
for nine years perhaps
[Music]
term and then if they're happy to
continue um it comes to full council
to reappoint um in terms of
independent people as a whole of course
they historically torridge have really
really struggled
to find independent people um
we've recently we've done three or four
adverts actually
um in recent history um
and we've done one a couple of months
ago and i've just had
two independent people apply for our
standards committee
and that we are actually three or four i
think short as a whole across toront
um but the constitution sets out um
that if they're happy to continue um it
comes to broad council and if paul
council are happy they can continue to a
point
thank you okay listen no other hands up
but it's been proposed i'll second it
all in favor michelle
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
all
um
thank you chair so um
in front of you you've got uh what i
think is a is a very
detailed report produced by the economic
development officer that goes through
the proposals of the scheme i i felt
certain members would be quite familiar
with it as it's very similar
in content to the future high street
fund that you've seen presented to you
several times before
with some specific changes based on
learning from the feedback we had from
mhclg on the future high street
application and
to make it more relevant to the leveling
up fund criteria so
those are the changes to the scheme what
we have is a is a confidential
two elements this for you to consider uh
the the finances associated with the
project
um are for you to take a look at and
then
if you were happy chair we would move
into part two for that consideration and
then move back
into part one for you to take the vote
um i wasn't going to run through it all
in detail um like i say i think you've
seen it before
at the last full council or the one
before i presented you the level one
fund criteria you selected this
project to go forward but again i'm
happy to take any
questions before you wanted to consider
the finances
specialists any questions
[Music]
so i can't say a lot
yes so that was a that was a virtual
event this year
and the feedback was uh you know
unanimously positive
um everybody seems to be really happy
with the scheme certainly the traders in
the town have selected this as the
preferred project and actively have
worked on the proposal
as we've progressed it we have the
potential partnership and the chamber of
commerce representative the government
supported the project
and they've helped to shape it as a
support at this point
i'll propose from the chair that we move
into part two
all in favor
i just forgot to take it down